hey kids welcome to the walking dead
again this is gonna be part 2 of episode
two you know I'm sayin now last time
[ __ ] kinda got a little real so we're
gonna be seeing what goes on you know
hey
okay so we're back let's see this see
this
check out the bar nothing really else
would have changed here okay
Oh stuck Oh doesn't be like [ __ ] it
sucked in why are they in like pitch
darkness well they're not okay
well cow Moo goes the cow it's okay
Clementine you can pet her it's okay go
ahead ya got
whoa oh it's warm that's where I'm able
could have a baby tonight we'll see
Clementine Maybelline what's this thing
dancin it's called a Salt Lick yeah but
don't lick it it's gross did you lick it
I don't know these kids can't say the
darnest things you know hey there hi
Andy yeah we met this woman up in the
woods she seemed to know your brother up
yeah he he probably talks a little more
nyata the [ __ ] is going on here um when
do you think we might eat hungry huh
don't worry Mama's cooking up some good
grub taking a [ __ ] murder us how's
the cow well better now we got duck on
the case yeah thanks yep
adele number two you know oh that man
Clementine
my head you found it she's like I'm not
like the other gas you said you would
listen could you give your hat to anyone
no did you see any strangers around the
motor and who might have taken it no why
it's probably nothing just let me know
if you ever see anything like that okay
I will Haley do you think you'll ever
have kids now am a criminal record I'd
like to someday maybe a little girl like
you that's nice you'd be a good daddy
well thanks it's really finding my hat
no prob did clue do you want to pet the
cow with me no but you go on let's see
you look around here it's looking around
here perfect for my second life anything
in here what's going on here
no no all right let me check if the
other one maybe this better give my
second wife if it's not as good with Sam
with my third of wife I guess ok yeah
her and her wife gave it to my third
wife let me see if anything is out
empty
empty it's very sad okay I guess things
get empty um you see it's gonna be Larry
at new place after I [ __ ] them up and
looks like a bunch of old dirty clothes
food smells pretty foul the [ __ ] is
going on here there's something fishy at
this part you know there's something
fishy okay let's see here it's a feeding
trough yeah fascinating fascinating
stuff by Leigh he would be a great
teacher one day very kind with the kids
as well okay is that what it Oh does
that leave that a feeding shop as well I
guess he doesn't know what this is
there's no marker okay guess well that's
not the keep on learning ourselves okay
use the store
you found it too huh
Lee they're hiding something behind this
door I got a quick look they got boxes
stuff something metal and sharp don't
get paranoid it's my job to be paranoid
we learn to become a whole family on
this far right now that's your L about
you what about Clem
I'll protect her no matter what I know
you look a guy with Katya what's his
name he locked it up real time to sit
and we came in I definitely heard a
noise back there Lee what my point is we
gotta know for sure so go find a hammer
or something and I'll have this thing
off in a second shelf in case then
farmers come mother [ __ ] aguila ya
think this through you smash the lock
then what if it turns out you're wrong
you just [ __ ] your chance to get a
good meal and those kids you're trying
to protect who's your head Kenny all
right professor what'd you have in mind
let me have a look at what we're dealing
with first hey Lee you know how to pick
a lock right no why would you say that
wow you're you know urban oh you are not
seeing what I think you're saying Jesus
man I'm from Florida crazy [ __ ] just
comes out of my mouth sometimes sorry
hmm but yeah dunno how to pick a lock
what see those screws instead of
breaking the padlock we can just take
off the assembly have a peek inside and
then replace it all again like nothing
ever happened all right sounds like you
got a play I'll hang around and keep an
eye on that guy with the cow Andy [ __ ]
off I thought that was Danny whatever
can I help you boys find something
[ __ ] mysterious what's fine this door
and II just to we keep it like sort of
people in the woods don't try and grab
him
be dead without
hey do me a favor don't [ __ ] around with
this door okay just you know mama gets
nervous Andrew I need your help again no
problem right away doc hmm no I'm a
straight shooter that's why I asked I'm
a straight shooter I'm just a straight
shooter you know strike Annie to get him
out of the board all right hey there
Andy yeah Danny mentioned he needed
something you say what should I can't
remember now sorry what a real liar all
right he write back doc [ __ ] then he
screw driver tonight
I still can't get that lock off the door
hmm you probably just need a screwdriver
or something that's exactly what I need
[ __ ] wasn't there like a lot of [ __ ] in
here
looks like a bunch of old dirty clothes
who smells does it give IV a trip in
there wasn't there screw drop around
here somewhere there was a [ __ ] time
to see here any screwdrivers or anything
around here and I go outside
the [ __ ] is that false alarm I'm back
[ __ ]
okay and we get a shoe job real quick
that seems so much darker inside than
outside Jesus oh so how does a woman
like yourself from this whole place
gummy guy and it's just burning plus I
had my boy's death held back I couldn't
do all about
[ __ ] scumbag
gotta be tools maybe where that that saw
was you know Ava's no no no I'm not a
hay bale guy i got it i'm not a hay bale
guy i'm more of a sitting down kind of
guy um in fact I've been here so long
that [ __ ] moss grows on my legs you
know like some [ __ ] yeah like oh yes
it's a small tool box I'm fascinating
can you open it up on this thing for
household repairs
it's multi-tool take that Chet we're
just gonna borrow a sec
ok
now I need to just get that guy out all
right
[ __ ] hate Larry no but really I sit
in this chair away too much i need those
that [ __ ] the astronauts use so they
don't like atrophy their muscles in
space hey there Andy yeah Danny needs
something again good all right all right
he write back doc yeah that's so easy
what the [ __ ] it takes so dark outside
their genes that can okay that's use
this door come on come on let's do this
false alarm I'm back [ __ ] it's like not
good enough
you
ah [ __ ]
hey there is yeah
alrighty they're not gonna be good
enough um
I bet something outside Danny needs
something yeah that I got to talk to
[ __ ] Kenny and see if there's
something do you do all right
said of like a [ __ ] fire arc ooh what
if I mess with this yeah I'll just mess
with it he'll come back okay
hey power switch
it's very Sharon should hope normal
[ __ ] dies
damn this thing is the worst piece of
[ __ ] yes oh he's tripping the breaker
I think I need this like [ __ ] it up
something's always true
you see if I can [ __ ] it up more yes
yes oh damn it it's moving fast so guys
I had to I had to oh damn it biggest
moving fast that's a [ __ ] just up
okay a thing is out too tight for my
bare hands oh so tight he's not you so
tight things there that should do it you
[ __ ] pocketed it hey that's going on
out here kid through avail damn it all
perfect perfect look at me my Levi jeans
I'm so [ __ ] cool it's like I know I'm
cool but I don't hide it i work in which
is like very adventurous you know kids
even they're secretly anyway it's a
second there is it oh now you gonna
close door behind you so the guy doesn't
[ __ ] see you yeah if I get got my
jeans on up feeling adventurous mom dad
dinnertime it's dinnertime okay honey
let's get that dad dad come on let's eat
Kenny come along honey Kenny come on
don't make the children wait I'll make
an excuse for you get that thing off yes
that's my boy Kenny that's my boy
and yet
I lose a scurry that'd be so [ __ ] bad
how is still don't you still need I
don't know let's see what happens I
think either multi tools I can't believe
like so far the bad things you've done
is this stolen screwdriver broke their
like main defense proud of bad people oh
[ __ ] it's a sex dungeon it's a sex
dungeon isn't it wait what don't block
boy didn't you hear the bell dinnertime
what the hell you gotta let my crew look
we have food here but Danny and I still
got to do a lot of hunting to keep
everyone fed when we catch something in
the woods we skin it and dress it back
there mama doesn't like us to make a
mess in the house so you see nothing to
worry about you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] Brenda you
are angel excuse the mess we had to
block the back door after Walker got
upstairs don't worry that was awhile ago
and ain't been back inside since
everybody sit down now go get the meal
oh this isn't a lot I could eat a horse
where's mom now don't you worry about
him I've already brought some food up
you just let him rest mind if I washing
our hands first bathrooms right accident
no go finally I'm sure to get under your
nails you've been mucking around and
look they're [ __ ] eating mark and
they're cannibals I'd be so [ __ ] up we
gotta find mark [ __ ] the [ __ ] in it I
know that was an excuse
alright mark
oh oh don't worry this brother is pretty
good at sneaking in now cuz he's black
just cuz he's pretty cool you know I
should people thought I said that cuz he
was black shame on you okay closet door
share the closet or just in case help
does make a racket anything I can steal
in here morphine box of candles medical
supplies power cord why is that not
plugged in and I don't might as well
just plug his hand [ __ ] that do
what the hell what the [ __ ] yeah what is
this stuff looks like a bunch of medical
waste in here me too SE li what would
dairy farmers need with their scary
stuff there are some really some zing
fee for candles smart I guess someone
needed some first aid recently what else
do I know dad who's that
[ __ ] it who cares holy [ __ ] where the
hair was mark but Brenda said it was up
here resting you're [ __ ] a [ __ ] a
phone books cookbooks nothing out of the
ordinary here what the [ __ ] what the
flying [ __ ]
mark
Lee mark hell happen brothers versus a
[ __ ] life I'll happened to your leg
man don't eat dinner that is so [ __ ]
up clear they're [ __ ] cannibals
spit that out Lee what's going on Lee
Jesus man did you find something Oh sit
your ass down Lee this lady has made you
a meal yeah Lee what's gotten into you
he just had a dog he could use some
goddamn manners you're eating human meat
that's crazy the hell do i scaring the
kids leave flee what the hell is wrong
with you darlin dogs him Lily it's
always something with this guy i was
eating that what is going on everything
could have turned out okay for you folks
he would have died anyway we gotta think
about living battle down honey growing
up in rural Georgia you're taught not to
waste it's how I was raised and how I
raised my boat now you got monsters
roaming around but do nothing but eat
people and for what to continue to rock
hill they eat some more we think we can
put that meat to better use oh I'm gonna
puke you're all sick sick in the head
Lee that's not a very nice thing to
imply [ __ ] a I'm [ __ ] speechless
Andy is right we go after folks who were
gonna die anyways one way or another
like y'all
can he get your dog Kenny no nobody's
going anywhere oh [ __ ] we got lots of
use for y'all right here what the bus
did [ __ ] walk away your guns down
we're walking out of here my family I
don't want to die mommy what is her eat
don't do something somebody do something
I'll kill you
that [ __ ] mark my man
Wow
dad is [ __ ] up oh damn door you can't
keep us in here open up I will tear you
[ __ ] apart with my bare hands gotta
find another way out of here yo sale
[ __ ] bastards open this door not
touch I will not deny dad or do it it
was a person I eat meat from a person
does that mean I'm gonna turn into
noclip it it it doesn't work like that
if he what I stopped us in time come on
dad now's not the time you okay
Clementine hey they didn't hurt you
today mm-hmm Oh Bob Lee those psychos
have my family we're stuck in a damn
meat locker we gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here oh yeah we're stuck fill the sucker
was the one who brought us here you all
just shut the [ __ ] up I'm scared don't
be it's gonna be okay I'm gonna find us
a way out of here I'm gonna [ __ ] Larry
up now not care if you could sit in oh
come on Larry do you really want to
attract their attention yeah I want to
attract their attention so I can't
[ __ ] kill him yes your new girlfriend
wasn't all she was cracked up to be what
the hell is your problem
refused to give me my day's rations
motor and you went out of your way to be
an [ __ ] yep golly I [ __ ] hate this
but guess what you're stuck with me I
plan to be around long after you go and
if you turn I'll be the one to put he
acts through your skull dad Oh burn oh
god damn i'm not gonna say that cuz he
is we're heading up our hearts what do I
have please sounder something on the way
it got caught you duck see those [ __ ]
have my family I know no I'm gonna get
out of here and find them they're not
gonna open the door could there be a
real bindings palace yes yes yes no such
luck well Lee amazing detective don't
want to know what kind oh I'll break
that down Georgia dad you can't go
yes sucks to be him we're not just kiss
him kiss dad come on yes'm God yes'm
he's stopped breathing I think he's had
a heart attack is he did he's not dead
stop buddy help me if he's dead he's not
dead oh [ __ ] he could turn into his
augustana me think about it you saw that
poor bastard at the motel now fast eater
what are you saying Lily I'm sorry I
truly truly am in a few minutes we're
gonna be stuck in a locked room a 6 foot
4 300 pound seriously pissed off dead
guy yeah we can bring it back please
morning later but right now we have to
keep him from coming back oh god damn it
Eddie he's not dead
maybe you're right but worse than finn
look Kenny back at the drugstore and we
all thought duck was written I gave him
the benefit of the doubt maybe we should
do the same now it was different duck
wasn't bitten but come on we know this
guy's not gonna make it that's your own
banner yet gotta destroy the brain come
on Liam right about this I know you've
got my back you always do I got Kenny I
got your back come on dad come on no
yeah get that salt lick that's saltlick
perfect well I mean lick up your tears
let me listen its ears I'm sorry I don't
you [ __ ] touch me kiss me kiss from a
test [ __ ] science here at fountain clip
okay why me Lilly said he wasn't dead
that [ __ ] is dead he was dead
Clementine but what if he wasn't well
sucking that promise
I'm held and you gotta be strong right
now I need you to be strong think about
think about something gasps something
think about I'm like what a click how
about your walkie-talkie those pretend
talks with your mom and dad don't those
make you feel better sometimes we're
gonna get out right you found a way out
I'm working on it look at Larry let me
look at my prize that I like in my brain
get away I just need to I told you to
get the [ __ ] away oh ok hey delay the
Sailor I'm sorry don't talk to me wait
don't [ __ ] talk to me
you've got to pull yourself together
living why for your sake so you can feel
better about so what you did well yeah
yes but right because you [ __ ] cares
so much about me ok that's all weird but
you think maybe we were too hasty well
that's that right now getting the [ __ ]
out of here we did what we had to
it's just you and me Lily's in no
condition to help us rescue your family
considering what just happened she
probably sad with the st. John's against
us well you're right it looks like we
have to kill her too all right now let's
get out of house get out here okay
nothing there nothing there uh yeah
ought to be an air duct behind this unit
may be big enough for one of us to fit
through I don't know Lee seems like a
long shot does the air conditioner come
off god I think I could take it off if I
had something to remove the screws yeah
he's an expert at all taken thing of the
horsley [ __ ] so there's something else
we could use I've got a rock rock won't
help coin might do the trick do you have
a coin this guy is so good at breaking
and entering now cuz it's black but just
because he's a street there you know oh
okay right there yep yeah coming off
that way mmm okay okay we need to get
coin we need to get that coin
my time wait doesn't he have a coin what
is that in my inventory just gotta
remove these screws that get this unit
off okay
okay what about check nothing's there is
it crop that one that way oh it's not
coming off that way we just examine it
if we could remove these screws the ACC
should come down easily at him okay no
can you got it penny or something on you
if the duck behind the air conditioner
is big enough we might have found our
way out of here yeah I need something to
loosen the screws I got nothing I got
tooth hang tight maybe I can scrounge
something ok I know it was necessary I
just wish clear didn't have to witness
[ __ ] like this don't worry what its
gonna do to her hmm no no now Turner ok
ok come on anything anything Lily's
probably the key to getting [ __ ] I
didn't you just leave me alone
I'm sorry that's a your face is all
Scottish gonna give out of here we need
your help and Larry's I think I may have
found a way out of here but I need
something to remove the screws on the
air conditioner if you had something I
could use as a screwdriver coin or
something now what about him look I know
this is a terrible I've this is [ __ ]
up Larry this may not be the most be
kool g playthrough but is the most
[ __ ] up in it all there's more useful
to you dent than a lie if he was alive
and had the key to getting us out of
here do you think he'd keep it to
himself how do you want my blessing to
loot his corpse yes permission Oh do
what you have to do ah thanks babe hello
I told ya it gets you back that's help
you any idea which pocket he keeps us
change in [ __ ] vulture and there I'd
get you back Elaine yeah yeah chin legit
no not surprised a chin strap that is
not easy back again we got two quarters
and
nice nice now you watch or anything now
I guess not okay well let's see what
happens just gonna remove these screws
and get this lid off
come on broski yes
you got it yeah one more should do it I
think it's hairstyles be cool
so I love the graphics gym they're like
park south who knows uh just wrong
there's our way out me get get get
Clementine can fit through looks like
it'll probably lead right into that back
room
all right be brave low what you think
you can do this I'm scared it's okay to
be scared we need you Clementine okay
I wanted the color seems and stupid like
how much they trust me like red was
Larry gonna be fun hers is like love
don't we try see if you [ __ ] the other
side of that door open it [ __ ] on
African players coming on oh he's a
gophone
kinda hope it doesn't switch to clone
with that I kind of like when it's just
one person alright let's see the CEC's
out how to spider what if she just
[ __ ] idea have you [ __ ] up oh ok I
guess it made it I made it did anyone
see you yeah look we're gonna [ __ ] no
not go leave me alone wait I can see him
it's not safe for God's sake lees didn't
even get to say goodbye oh yeah oh my
god i forgot i totally forgot about that
just [ __ ] shot the brick on it he's
added to stay here take care of lovely
ok I will
I've only [ __ ] um Glenn was here he's
pretty cool guy
oh this is the song room
let's [ __ ] I told you they were up at
this room it's a goddamn human
slaughterhouse
dad is [ __ ] up this is all pretty
[ __ ] up
take this hey hook oh I got my piece I
got my six I forgot to this we're gonna
do is realize these people that [ __ ]
we're gonna do this realize Oh take a
cab back to yeah yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] we're gonna get a [ __ ]
with answer when I [ __ ] yeah not now
we're getting that we're getting the
[ __ ] hook [ __ ] that [ __ ] we're doing
this we're doing this fatally get that
[ __ ] back okay just put your people yes
yeah let's say this see this so what's
the plan and tell mrs. so caught up in
his own ran that we could probably sneak
right up on it just stick behind me in
case anything goes down when we get to
the front grabbed his gun sounds good
okay you ready that's ghetto stay close
who had to kill this [ __ ] not [ __ ]
splinter style like we're all styling up
all you
[ __ ]
dead what are you doing outside the bar
oh so just go into place like you said
mama says you can't keep that
if one key
hmm
three
this is my team when I 13 biggie his
walk right out soon as he passed jump
see you guys do it what's turned out
another gets his [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] me my [ __ ] in Santa
this guy's down where's my family
[ __ ] you can't have him we need the
bed Oh can't leave come on just go oh I
forgot the campus i'll be there
let's choice you this sucker you see you
understand that don't you you can have
me in the world work now get part of
yourself so others can live pork never
volunteered to be food you gotta keep me
alive if you kill me let me get staging
you can't eat it you're already tainted
you ain't gonna kill me just like you
didn't kill Jolie exactly exactly Oh
part number time I think you're there
nice icons that gotcha let's go I'll
keep funding a seat good
math react related explain that right
yeah I guess get a teddy bears up later
Jimmy
you can't get the gun I can't remember
[ __ ]
hug is that a walker oh [ __ ] I stuff the
belt is that electrical working I bet
it's [ __ ] not [ __ ] no [ __ ] way
Holly
so tell her to let your pants Oh Shh oh
this guy ok we heard dreams as we were
coming up to the house
get out of here why what's going on dead
quiet tell me what's going on me I can
help there he's dead they've chopped off
marks legs and tried to feed up to us is
everyone else okay Duncan Koch in the
house and I don't know where the [ __ ] in
he is all right we're coming in to help
the main gate is too dangerous go around
the fence and see if there's a back way
in I'll keep looking for Kenny do you
have a weapon I don't leave home without
it good then stickles leak be careful
that's pretty cool too nice man all
right let's do this [ __ ] that's good
oh I'm taking boy and baby is that you
what's going on out there yeah he's me
this remorse liar of all time don't trip
come on now you know you don't want to
do this
shooter
hey
wow that was [ __ ] up go Brenda why
don't you pick another stamp pretty come
on now you know you don't want to do
this
her dumb [ __ ] sighs sighs I had to do
that I had to do that guess the good
news for real man I guess revealing the
store real gold printer
cool but I want to do this
tarragon begun
ding clock what you do it doesn't have
to end like this just let me go oh my
god is that like zombie mark
stay back
better go Brenda
thank you
I don't want to kill you Lee
please don't make this any worse
yeah get it get it
I said don't move [ __ ]
my god [ __ ]
that ain't gonna happen to rocket asset
and don't shut up [ __ ] these people
thank you all look at what you've done
you think I'm playing here boys all we
wanted was gas we came to you facebook
Harley you park
hey man yeah this get y'all [ __ ] this
[ __ ] out there
le help Oh
I
all right hook yeah so now I know my
ABCs
watch me kill like an audience like an
audience right out laughs all right up
top LF good for good luck
is that all you got li you were it
it's over [ __ ] you Judith Danny bummer
get out here soon oh [ __ ]
they're both dead if you do let go [ __ ]
if you know who
gonna [ __ ] them up don't you dare walk
away from me Lee
get back here and finish the sling
[ __ ]
as be done
yeah I made a lot of tough choices but
you know i'ma later she hits me
let's take a she
kind of real their life
yeah walk of shame back could we lose
here mark I'm ducks at Kenny about Larry
yes oh [ __ ] climb family walk with Haley
I'd say I'm sorry for leaving the motel
unattended but you know we sure hope
when you did yall you haven't taken that
saturday d we might not have gotten out
of there were they really killing people
for food yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah I'm
Clementine ate some oh it's my fault I
panicked and didn't stop her my god does
she know she's not stealing every man
can't you manage to have this while she
was in the house she said it was with
your stuff yeah I found it while I was
looking for the people who SAT mark do
you want it why don't you keep it
sometimes it helps to have something you
can document your thoughts on there's no
batteries in it okay ah how are you
doing oh I'll be shots a lot of just not
as young as I used to be hon go on ahead
and give me in li a second oh it's just
like a side grace thank god there's
gonna be fallout 4 jun Lily's dad
I would imagine so what do you think
I'm with you Kenny will do what has to
be done you're damn right listen that
are back at the Motor Inn is just about
ready I've changed my mind I want you to
come with us when we leave hey yeah hell
yeah we're a team man me and you by
taking out Larry before he turned you
saved all of us and that meat locker and
that saved my family too yeah not say
you earned it okay come on Clementine
stay close we did you have to kill those
men yeah I'm sorry you had to see that
but I only did it to protect us because
they tried to hurt us yes okay hey Dad
how's he know oh [ __ ] my personal pins
out of your car oh god no more strangers
no someone's like broken down let's take
the broken down nose right yeah
what if it's glendive insane no like it
a lot like its blend
don't shoot we're here to help and good
looking around looking around
what is that figures oh maybe you gotta
see this it's a shitload of food and
supplies back here what the [ __ ] this
food could save all of us not all of us
to too little look we don't know if
these people are dead if they come back
then we're just monsters who came out of
the woods and ruined their lives this
stuff isn't ours dad whose car is it
don't worry about that duck it's ours
now what's the bone bender don't worry
what if it's not
well what if it's not abandoned what if
it is someone's you're right we
shouldn't take you to Clementine what
did you get some meal back there the
rest of us missed out on we have to take
this stuff
we've done enough damage already you
mean by that come on Kenny between this
and the meat locker you know what it
means oh yeah suit yourself the rest of
us are taking this stuff huh okay what
we got in here look there's more food in
that box no antibiotics what else see if
there's any water here why they just
take the car I would just get it dry I
don't know why they carrying it Lee
there's a brief agartala bleach it
Clementine
she's good thanks whatever man it's
gonna get cold out eventually hey there
were some batteries in one of those
boxes I thought they might work in your
camcorder here you can have some too for
your walkie talkie battery son think you
can handle them we're not gonna let me
live that down are you
Lee you're gonna want to see this the
[ __ ] is that
[ __ ] some grid point oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] they're stalking him Jake bars
blend on all y'all [ __ ] stickers from
the same flux they call ya'll bandits
but you're [ __ ] oh darling baby look
at you look at you oh you need a mama
sweetheart we won't let that maintenance
get you where we go so sexy your mother
okay
can you help me find it sure what did
you lose it I had it a couple days ago
burroughs thinking you're safe sitting
there acting odd things are the way they
reason the dead don't kill their own
living you gotta be afraid of the people
I cues to comp friends people oh [ __ ]
don't worry little girl and it's got
their eye on that dairy long as they
keep getting food from them you be safe
I promise [ __ ] since there is gone the
banners are gonna go insane oh [ __ ] well
let's see this let's say that's making
his done pal ain't nothing left we got
to get the hell out of here Lee I need
you to back me up on this it's this all
you got I told you this town is tapped
do you have any idea what he hasn't you
to get all that we need to leave oh I
said about the farm last night not much
raised it's starting to add up I need to
get to the coast get him out of all this
Madam's [ __ ] Benton Lily's not doing so
good huh well we killed her dad we did
your dad do you mean lay behind our
account of that better than us at least
could be folks who have all these [ __ ]
figured out do people get mad when
they're scared
sometimes yeah they do this is crazy I'm
the one keeping this group going we can
sort this all out all right we can sort
this out I'll tell you what we need to
sort out we can't let one person [ __ ]
this up for everyone else um it's her oh
[ __ ] all right guys well thanks for
watching let's take a look real quick
chop leg off yep helped kill Larry okay
and kill both yes stole from the car and
I'll lead people [ __ ] Steelers all
right well y'all people thank you for
watching and and I hope you realize what
it takes to survive you know what I'm
saying thank ya all right suckers have a
good day
you